the Joe Rogan experience one of the main
reasons you're here I want to talk to
you it's because you're my favorite
Mexican and now we have a Mexican
American heavyweight champion of the
[ __ ] world that's crazy how
crazy sad that's insane
I can't even love Mexico yeah Jesus
Christ I didn't know Mexico had a
heavyweight boxer oh my god the [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] he's what America needs right
now with all this border wall crisis
[ __ ] a heavyweight champion that's
Mexican yeah come on son and one that's
[ __ ] good and one that has a big belly
and he knocks out a dude who looks like
he's chiseled out of granite I mean no
one has ever had a better body than
Anthony Joshua you've only had a
different body no one's had a better
body he's like what is he like six seven
or some [ __ ] and I said I don't know God
dude Anthony Joshua was the one of the
best-built heavyweight boxers evolved
and he's legit he was a champ and all
that Olympic gold medalist the champ
knocked out Vladimir Klitschko I mean
he's a [ __ ] monster from the UK from
the UK okay yeah he was the champ and he
was supposed to fight big baby Miller
and big baby Miller tested positive for
the Mexican supplements ironically
enough boom that's Anthony Joshua I mean
come on Sonya how tall is he cuz he's
gigantic I've had a 12 pound because
Andi Ruiz looked short in that fight six
six yet
yeah but Ruiz is like six - he just
looked tiny when he's standing next to
Joshua Josh was a giant of a man and
just [ __ ] jacked what does it say is
wait-listed us 249 240 online I wonder
if that was for the last fight because
I'm sure with a giant dude like that it
varies back and forth but so I was out
to dinner and I get a text from Brendan
chop Brendan Schaub he with the spoiler
alert he said [ __ ] Josh who got knocked
out and I was like no and I go what
happened and he goes he got [ __ ] up in
the seventh round I am Mexican and he
goes I'm sick I go you're sick I go I'm
happy as [ __ ] I love I couldn't wait to
come home and watch it I love when crazy
[ __ ] happens this was my favorite thing
in fights look at that guy look here
no disrespect champ
but him jokes about it himself I'm
trying to get him in here too oh that
would be crazy in his body I mean it
looks like a regular dude what if he got
shredded how much would he weigh why
would he wait get shredded no but it
might be a middle way right I would feed
him on the sneak tip I'd wake him up in
the middle of the night with some great
Mexican food that dude needs to stay
exactly how he is see look he's got
muscles under there like look at his
stomach he's just got some body fat on
them but here's one thing if you do have
great cardio one thing that body fat can
do is it can protect you somewhat it's
like wearing eight sweaters I've joked
around about this before and people
think I'm bullshitting and I kind of am
a little bit because I know most of the
impact gets in there but if you were
gonna fight a guy and right before you
fought him he puts on a vest made out of
fat and meat and stitches it up and it
sticks out like [ __ ] 10 extra inches
you'd be like hey what is all this what
are you doing you can't put that on and
then if you hit him to the body and he
barely reacts you'd be like [ __ ] I can't
believe this guy's cheating with this
fat vest you think about that [ __ ] yeah
good cardio and you got some fat around
your gut that [ __ ] might protect you
look at Daniel Cormier yep phaidor
look at phaidor you're dealing with
these giant dudes giant dudes who can
[ __ ] you up with one shot there might
actually be an advantage to having a gut
and that's not [ __ ] at all hmm it's
not ideal in the lower weight class
looking back guts you brought back 30
packets I'm thinking of growing my own
chicks only dated dudes with guts that
could be the new thing did you see that
that gif on Brendon shops page of DJ
Khaled is that how you say his name
who's a big fellow himself climbing out
of a golf cart with a shirt open let me
show you that I don't want to read the
caption see my problem was sharing this
is I want to know who the [ __ ] made this
cuz it's really funny I wish I knew the
dude to give him credit you know
oh it says it there the creator of the
the gif can I see it yeah I put it up on
their forum Jim
hold on James
Tami's ghetto might be a problem
copyright issue somebody might have
stole it from somebody else
you got to talk in the microphone people
yes yes [ __ ] someone okay look at
this all the big men all the big man
headed to brunch with their shirt open
today after the injuries would he's
bringing back guts dude that would be a
man
dude he's super friendly like really
nice guy thanked his mom she told his
mom after the fight you know we don't
have to suffer anymore we this has
changed our lives you know it's
beautiful it's prettier than last I mean
I was I was crazy into boxing before I
saw UFC 2 once I saw UFC 2 I kind of
just dropped boxing but I was way into
boxing had stacks of Ring Magazine all
over my house I wouldn't throw them away
I was way into it and all we had as
Mexicans in the heavyweight division was
Alex Garcia remember him yeah he was he
broke the top 10 yeah he was up there
for a little bit but he just you know
that's that's the closest we ever got
unless there's been someone else since
then this was like 1990 I haven't
followed boxing at all well that's why I
was big for mexican-americans when Cain
Velasquez was the UFC heavyweight champ
that was the first ever Mexican
heavyweight champ in combat sports Yeah
right
am i correct yeah it's weird though in
MMA people aren't racists in MMA really
as much is boxing they're really raised
like boxing I'm always going for the
Mexican I don't [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
you know yeah we talked about this but
in jujitsu guys I don't care what
nationality you are in MMA
[Applause]